[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends
thank you for tuning in to this live q
and a program
i'd like to know where you send us your
questions
and we do everything possible to answer
those questions
i want to give you the address of the
place where you can send us your
questions we have
many we're kind of backed up but you'll
see it on the screen
the address is tv at some tv dot org
tv at some tv dot org
i also want to remind you of our anchor
school of theology
which is going to take place in person
june 21-26 and it's going to be at
fresno central seventh-day adventist
church
we have about 60 people that have
already registered and paid
and we hope to have more we have plenty
of capacity
and so i hope that you'll make plans to
come and be blessed by the
study of revelation 15 through
revelation 22.
in fact i have with me pastor daniel
gouveia the pastor
of fresno central seventh-day adventist
church and
he along with the board graciously
opened the door
for us to have anchor over there it's
just been remodeled it's beautiful
thank you pastor gover oh thank you for
coming and blessing our church with
anchor bible school we
we are privileged to have you there
thank you very much
well let's begin with the word of prayer
and then we'll delve right into our
questions all right
let us pray father in heaven thank you
for giving us the opportunity to
meet and to address some interesting
bible
questions i pray that the holy spirit
may guide us
and that everyone listening to these
words and watching this program
may be blessed we pray in the name of
jesus amen
amen okay we have an interesting
question
i've never heard this question before
but it's uh interesting
it says like this why are multiple
churches
in the world jesus said i will build my
church
not churches so how do we approach the
answer to that question
well that's a very interesting question
jesus did say i will build my church in
matthew 16 verse 18.
um actually there's another text i
thought
initially when i read part of the
question i thought it would go into this
text
that is quoted often that is john 10
verse 16
where jesus says and other sheep i have
which are not of this fold them also i
must bring
and they will hear my voice and there
will be
one flock and one shepherd so
yes these are texts that sometimes
people
struggle with because why do we have
such a great number 30 40 000 christian
denominations
that all claim the name of jesus and
they all say
we are the true church well
i think first of all um we need to
understand that god always had a church
since the beginning of time um in adam
and in eden god had a church adam and
eve they were the first human worshipers
of god
and then you have the descendants of
seth that
opposing the descendants of cain were
faithful to god were calling upon the
name of god
unfortunately they mingled with the
descendants of cain
and we had the events that brought about
the flood
at the time of the flood we had noah a
remnant right and
noah and his family were the true church
of god in this world and they were
preserved
we continued throughout the bible god
called abraham his descendants
the people of israel even in egypt they
were the people of god and god were
was trying to really bring them to a
place where
he could bring them out and make them
his special people in the wilderness
they were
wandering for 40 years but that was the
people of god and god had his church
now when you look at all that and even
when we think about
the new testament the hebrews
after the exiled judah jerusalem
when you think about that people not
everyone in that people were entirely
committed to god
not everyone was following all the truth
that they
should be following at that time but
there was
there were people who were truly
faithful to the lord
and there were even people who were not
a part of israel
that god we see in the bible that even
jesus commended the faith of the
centurion
that asked for him to heal his servant
that syrophenician woman he she said
parade is your faith
so meaning that the church is not only
it was not only
the people of israel at that time and
today it's not only a particular
denomination when i when i see jesus
saying my sheep will hear my voice there
will be one one flock and one
shepherd
of course ideally i think about the
future and
no more barriers denominational barriers
or
social economical cultural barriers in
the great future that god is preparing
for his people
but even today i believe that
and there's another text here that i
would like to quote is in
acts chapter 10. i believe that today
like throughout all the story of sin
on planet earth god has people
everywhere that are faithful to him and
that he accepts
as part of his people part of the body
of christ even though some
have not heard all that there is to hear
about the gospel and about the bible so
acts chapter 10
we re i'm reminded of peter speaking to
cornelius verse 34 and 35
then peter opened his mouth and said in
truth i perceive that god chose no
partiality
but in every nation whoever fears him
and works
righteousness is accepted by him
now what i'm what am i saying as a
pastor of the seventh-day adventist
church of course i believe that
the seventh-day adventist church was
called by god as a people
that has a special mission given by god
to proclaim the everlasting gospel the
three angels messages
in all the world and i do believe that
we are a prophetic movement
and we are the remnant church of god in
the last days of earth's history
however i do not believe that only
seventh-day adventists will go to heaven
i do not believe that only seventh-day
adventists will be faithful to god in
the end times because we read in
revelation
chapter 18 verse 4 come out of her my
people
and this is god speaking to people who
are in babylon
which is a false church or actually a
union of false churches at that time
that will have still a lot of people
that are
of the true church of god and that jesus
is calling them
to be faithful to the bible and the
bible only
right you know i looked up the word
churches
in the new testament it's used 36 times
in the new testament
and i like to answer this question by
saying you know
take for example microsoft yes the
company microsoft
it's one company but it has many
branches
yes so god has one church
it's global yeah but it has many
branches
and in fact the new testament very
clearly says that there's not only the
church like jesus said i will build my
church but
the apostle paul recognized that there
are churches
you know maybe we can just read a couple
of texts acts chapter 9 verse 31
acts 9 verse 31. is one example
where we find the word churches used do
you want to read that
yes so acts 9 31 then the churches
throughout
all judea galilee and samaria had peace
and were edified and walking in the fear
of the lord
and in the comfort of the holy spirit
they were multiplied so the bible
recognizes that there are churches
but there's one church globally the
apostle paul also iraq
also recognized that there is you know
church and then there are churches where
he says that the church
is the ground of truth yes so
there's no contradiction between jesus
building his church
and the church having many branches on a
global scale
yes i also was reminded of acts chapter
and maybe this is a more direct
answer to probably the spirit of the
question if i can't interpret it right
um acts chapter 20 the apostle paul was
talking it to the
the elders of ephesus and he said
um verses 28 through 30 therefore take
heed to yourselves
and to all the flock among which the
holy spirit has made you
overseers to shepherd the church of god
which he purchased with his own blood
for
i know this that after my departure
savage wolves will come in among you
not sparing the flock also from among
yourselves
man will rise up speaking perverse
things
to do to draw away the disciples after
themselves
so even in the early church there was
already
some divisions caused by people who were
trying to steal the sheep
of jesus so definitely today we have a
lot of denominations that are not
preaching
the truth as we find it in god's word
now by the grace of god there are
christian denominations that are
preaching a lot of truth
but we are to keep coming back to the
bible
and to have the bible as our own as our
only rule of faith and practice amen
amen
that's what jesus meant when he said
upon this rock
i will build my church and to build the
rock means to build
on the word of god yes amen okay next
question
this is a good one since jesus didn't
sin
did he experience addiction
great question well first of all i think
it would be interesting to read here
hebrews chapter 4 verse
15 when we have one of the bible
declarations about jesus being sinless
never having committed any sin that is
and we see hebrews chapter 4 verse 15
for we do not have a high priest and we
know it's talking about jesus because
verse 14
identifies him we do not have a high
priest who cannot
sympathize with our weaknesses
but was in all points
tempted as we are yet without
sin now the interesting thing here
is that he can sympathize with all of
our weaknesses now
i do not believe if you look at
addictions like we normally read the
word addiction is about something bad
i don't believe that jesus was ever
addicted to
anything bad jesus never committed any
sin
not even by a thought not by a word not
by an action so no jesus was never
addicted to anything bad so
in that sense he never had addictions
however
he is able to sympathize with all our
weaknesses
being because he was tempted in all
points as we are now
we may ask how can he understand a drug
addict
since he was never addicted to drugs
well
first of all we need to remember that
the bible says that he came to
bear all of our sins all of our
iniquities
isaiah 53 verse 4 and verse 5.
surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows
yet we esteemed him stricken smitten by
god and afflicted
but he was wounded by our transgressions
he was pierced for our iniquities
the chastisement for our peace was upon
him and by his stripes we are healed
meaning jesus experienced the guilt
that we all have experienced he
suffered all of that for us on the cross
he knows the weight
of guilt and the the feeling of having a
heart that is crushed by that guilt
and by that infirmity
also he suffered experiences he went
through experiences
that actually are close
to that feeling of craving when you're
addicted to something because in the
desert he fasted for 40 days and 40
nights right so he craved food for
because he was a human being like us so
he understands everything we go through
but
to be entirely biblical no he never had
addictions to anything
bad actually the guilt of adam
and all of his descendants fell upon
christ exactly so he felt the anguish of
guilt which was not his
yes it belonged to all of humanity
you know matthew 27 and verse 34 kind of
helps us with this
you know there's a lot of drug addiction
these days
yes jesus was tempted to take drugs
when he was hung up when he hung on the
cross
matthew 27 and verse 34 if you want to
read that verse pastor
they gave him sore wine mingled with
gall to drink
but when he had tasted it he would not
drink
and of course that was a narcotic which
the roman soldiers actually gave
to people on crosses so that they would
not feel
the pain of what they were going through
maybe i can read this statement from
desire of ages page 746
those who suffered death by the cross
it was permitted to give stupefying
portion
potion to deaden the sense of pain
this was offered to jesus but when he
had tasted it he refused it
yes he would receive nothing that could
be cloud his mind
his faith must keep fast hold upon god
this was his only strength to be cloud
his senses would give
satan an advantage so people who are
going through depression
and through anxiety and through guilt
you know the temptation is to kind of
calm it by taking drugs and doing other
things which are wrong
but jesus refused to do that because he
needed a clear mind
to overcome the temptations of satan and
we can
connect that with hebrews 2 18 saying
that in
that which he was tempted he is able to
help to secure
those who are tempted so if anyone
hearing these words or if we ourselves
sometimes are tempted to
do anything that is bad and that
if if anyone is wrestling with an
addiction
actually in the bible and in the example
and in the power and grace of jesus we
have
the answer to be able to overcome sin
amen
jesus said in the world you'll have
tribulation but be of good cheer i have
overcome the world
if we accept him as our savior if he
lives lives in our hearts
he will give us the power to overcome
these temptations
yeah the apostle paul said i can do all
things
but then he qualifies it by saying
through christ
who strengthens me amen there's no
temptation that has come upon us which
is too strong to resist
first corinthians 10 verse 13 and you
know
god is able to keep us from falling amen
the book of jude
24 and 25 so there are beautiful
promises in the bible that we can claim
amen if we are tempted to become
addicted or if we are
addicted amen now there's one positive
uh
well i would like to also read the
question
in a positive way now i know this is
forcing a little bit the question but
can it be that there is a good addiction
and
i was thinking jesus was addicted to
prayer
you know he was addicted to loving god
and loving people and serving people
so i think that anybody who is wrestling
with
bad addictions if you just give his
heart entirely to god or her heart
entirely to god and ask lord
help me to do good things to be addicted
to what is good you know to prayer to
bible study
to serving others to promoting the
kingdom of god on earth those are the
things we should be addicted to
amen you know i know pastor govaia is
addicted to the bible
because as i look at his bible it's
underlined in many different colors
and there's notes in the margins
and you know he has practically the
whole bible underline well this is one
of them
that's an amazing it's amazing looking
bible
and so i know that you're addicted to
bible study but that's a good addiction
a
i recommend it amen okay let's go to the
next question
this one is based on daniel 9 26
and here's the question i'm going to
read the verse because it's put here on
the
email that was sent and after three
score in two weeks
shall messiah be cut off but not for
himself
and the people of the prince that shall
come shall destroy the city and the
sanctuary
and the end thereof shall be with a
flood and on to the end of the war
desolations are determined now here's
the question
while i understand about the 70-week
prophecy
and the significance of the 69th week
somehow i am not able to find this time
period
in the charts or where it is attributed
please explain and if there are
any resources which can assist me
[Music]
yeah that's a great question i think the
confusion sometimes arises because of
the way that gabriel explained the
prophecy to daniel
he first talks about seven weeks right
and then
62 weeks we read verse 25
know therefore and understand that from
the going forth of the command to
restore and build jerusalem
until messiah the prince that is until
the coming of jesus in the time that he
was anointed
there shall be seven weeks and
62 weeks so we are adding the first
seven weeks
to 62 weeks and then
when we read verse 26 it says and
after the 62 weeks now when he is
coming back to this point in time or to
this portion of time 62 weeks
of course it is implied that we have to
add it to the first seven weeks
right so it's not the first 62 weeks
here it is
actually seven weeks plus 62 weeks in
total
79 weeks that is why it says
after the 62 weeks meaning after 69
weeks in the line of prophecy because
because we had the first seven weeks the
messiah shall be cut off
so in that last week the seventh seventh
um in the the week number 70 and
the messiah shall be cut off how do we
know when he would be cut off
just because of the next verse verse 27
when it says then he shall confirm a
covenant with many for one week that is
the last week of the seventy weeks
but in the middle of the week he shall
bring an end to sacrifice and offering
so as we remember that jesus was pierced
and died for us on the cross
when he died the veil of the temple was
torn into into
from top to bottom meaning that those
sacrifices were no longer valid
and actually the true sacrifice had been
offered on the cross by god himself
so that is why we know that in the
middle of the week the middle of the
that last week of the 70 weeks that was
the date when jesus should be crucified
so this 62 weeks we have to add
them to the first seven weeks that we
find in verse
25. so basically what it's doing is
there's going to be seven weeks 62 weeks
and after the 62 weeks which implies
that the seven weeks
are included so it's going to with a
sequence
seven weeks 62 weeks and then after that
the final week
exactly so so basically there's uh
there's really no confusion the
structure is a little bit different than
what we would normally think of but i
think as
you look at the context it's very clear
so can you review the events that take
place during the final week so
during the final week and that is that
is a week that starts with the baptism
of christ in the
year 27 a.d fall of the year 27 a.d
jesus should be
baptized because it says seven weeks
plus 62 weeks in the messiah the prince
messiah means the anointed mashiach in
hebrew
and jesus was anointed by the holy
spirit when he was baptized
year 27 a.d and three and a half years
later
in the middle of the week the sacrifice
and offering should cease
meaning jesus should die exactly in the
middle of the week that was the year
31 a.d the spring of the year 31 a.d
actually the east or the passover today
we call it easter but
the passover that was exactly when they
were
supposed to kill the passover lamb
that's when jesus was sacrificed on the
cross 31
a.d and then the bible says verse 27
that he shall confirm a covenant with
many for one week so
throughout those seven years the last
week
of years of the 70-week
bible prophecy we see that the gospel
was being preached
specifically to the jewish nation
and for three and a half years the
gospel still needed to be preached
in jerusalem the bible says in acts
chapter 6 verse 7 if i'm not mistaken
that a lot of priests
were obedient to the faith so a lot of
jewish people were converted
but unfortunate unfortunately at the end
of those three and a half years after
jesus died at the end of that
seventh at that uh week number seven
seventy um stephen proclaimed
the gospel publicly and we read that in
acts chapter 7 and the beginning of acts
chapter 8
and we see that the jewish leadership
rejected the gospel they rejected the
speech that stephen was offering
inspired by god
they stoned stephen and they persecuted
the christian
church in jerusalem and we are told that
they
spread everywhere and proclaim the
gospel than in
other nations so the gospel was taken
to the different nations after the end
of the 70 weeks
that was determined especially for the
jewish people
like gabriel said to daniel and
really that was already predicted by
christ
in the parable of the vineyard you know
where god sends messengers to get
the fruit yes and they despise them and
get rid of many of them and then he
sends other messengers
the first group of messengers is after
sinai and then after the captivity
there's a second group of messengers
and then god sends his son
he says they're going to respect my son
but they said
let's get the son he's the heir let's
and they cast him out
of the vineyard and they killed him and
so then jesus says what do you think
will be done to those who did that they
they said it themselves right and they
incriminated themselves yeah only
afterwards that they realized that he
was talking about them
exactly uh you know actually let's go to
i think it's um where is the parable of
the
vineyard workers um i believe that uh
it's in matthew 21 i think 21
matthew chapter 21 and uh yes verse
beginning with verse 33
let's just read verse 43
to see the conclusion of what jesus said
therefore i say to you
the kingdom of god will be taken from
you
and given to a nation bearing the fruits
of it and so who was that nation that
the kingdom was given to i believe that
that nation
was now people from all the nations who
accept the gospel
right they was taken to all the world um
the christian church
is now the people of god of course those
who are faithful to him in every
place of the world are the true israel
and when you look at the book of acts
you know stephen is stoned in chapter
seven
yes in chapter eight the gospel goes to
samaria
chapter 9 saul of tarsus is converted he
becomes the great apostle paul
then in chapters 10 and 11 you have the
experience with cornelius
which means that the gospel is now going
to the gentiles and then afterwards you
have the apostle paul going to the
entire roman empire
so it's interesting that the book of
acts corroborates what we find in the
prophecy of the 70 weeks
definitely everything falls into place
yeah
and of course for those who might be
confused
this is not talking about literal weeks
this is talking about
weeks of years weeks of years so 490
days which is 70 weeks would be the
equivalent 490 years
which begin in 457 bc
and they end in the year 34 a.d
uh when stephen is cr is actually stoned
yes so yeah well i don't think that we
have time
uh to deal with any more questions do
you have any final comments pastor
well i just uh want to encourage people
who are watching to continue sending in
their questions
i want to thank secrets unsealed for
their support of the
the local church fresno central
seventh-day adventist church pastor boar
was
a the senior pastor of this church for
20 years
and we are happy to still invite him to
preach often
and to see that we are working together
well it's my pleasure and my wife's
pleasure to still belong to fresno
central seventh adventist church
you know the pandemic has kind of thrown
us a knuckleball
to use a baseball term uh but you know
we've been able to
come back to church a couple of times in
the last few weeks
because the pandemic is kind of winding
down in california and other places so
it's really our pleasure to to be
members of fresno central church
and thank you for your good leadership
and for being willing to come
and share in this program thank you it's
a privilege to be here
okay folks let me remind you where you
can send your questions
you send them we do the research and we
do everything possible to answer those
questions
you'll probably find it on the screen
the address
is tv at some tv dot org once again tv
at some tv dot org we want to thank you
for taking the time on tuesday
afternoons at 4 30 pacific time
to tune in to our program and we trust
that next time
you will be with us once again god bless
[Music]
you